this is bertha  she's a lima more specifically a  cockerel's shafak  while all of madagascar lima's are rare  she's unique even for her kind  there are over 100 different types of  lemurs in madagascar but none quite like  the cockrule shifak  found only in the northwestern forest of  madagascar sherfox move differently than  most lemurs they stand on two feet and  use their powerful hind legs to leap up  to 30 feet in a single jump  their beautiful fur also distinguishes  them  their cream-colored bodies feature  maroon patches  bertha loves her peanuts but shafaks  aren't picky eaters they consume  everything from leaves and flowers to  bark and deadwood  biologists estimate that less than 10  000 remain in the wild as major habitat  loss and hunting continues to increase  this is the [ __ ] rules shafak